[Music]
hey hey hey what's up everybody zacky
here from geek culture
with another fantastic unboxing of the
model combat 11 ultimate collectors
edition featuring
the subzero mask bust of course what we
have here is the scorpion mask bust from
the motor combat 11 collectors edition
for the ps4
and now
it's another
collector's edition
for the ps5
yeah
so along with the subzero mask bus
there's a few
in-game
dlc content that's included with
the ultimate collector's edition so
let's
go ahead with the unboxing
yeah
so let's just put this away for a little
bit
just give this guy a center stage we
have a sleeve now
you know we couldn't get it
in a good condition with the sleeve you
can see that there's some test but
nevertheless it's what matters on the
inside right
so
here you can take a look
uh stunning graphics of course a little
bit of flex from the reviewers
um with the definitive experience so
what you get
for the model combat 11 ultimate
collector's edition is
a
free
ps5 upgrade so you have visual
enhancements
4k dynamic resolution
of course significantly reduced load
times cross play and more
so
yeah
you've also got all 37 fighters
two cinematic stories and of course you
have all the features and modes included
in the game let's just skip this and
let's just open it so you guys can see
what's the redo what's going on here of
course if they cannot just leave this is
what it looks like
very nice simple
minimalistic packaging
unravel this
and
the first thing at the top is of course
the
mortal kombat
ultimate edition of the game for
the ps5 yes
right of course we have the mortal
kombat 11
still book case
very nice mk
with the
motor combat logo let's take a look
inside
oh and it's a very heavy metallic thing
i believe it's a fridge magnet metallic
blue
motor combat
logo symbol
and
we do have
the yellow
gold version if you will of the same
thing there's two magnets here
this time
the subzero
version has three magnets so you can
snap them on your fridge or simply you
know
put in some metal service if you will
very nice and with the steel book you
know you kind of have the symbol here
it's d boss and since it's metal
you know you can kind of get it fit
yeah wow that looks way better now
awesome
and what you have here is the mortal
kombat 11
collector's edition
certificate of authenticity
we have the 1309th
copy
of 5000
it's a nice
metal card
very cool
[Music]
so let's take this out
blank
and
what we have is a big styrofoam box
encased in it should be
the
sub zero
mask
bust
let's put this aside
set aside sub-zero for a quick minute
opening up the styrofoam box we have wow
the sub-zero mask bust
this can go away
and there you have it
let's take this plastic out
nice and carefully
[Music]
and voila ladies and gents
the base itself is plastic it's not
metal so don't expect your logo to snap
in place just like the scorpion one as
well it can come out
pretty easily
so with that let's cover some of the
detailing
of the
subzero mask
so
nice rotation here
very very interesting base
with the mortal kombat 11 logo here as
you can see mortal kombat 11
looks like yeah it's all resin plastic
resin but it does
have that look of leather
it's a very nice leather sheen a little
bit of um some rough texture to imitate
that leather feel and of course
sub-zero's mask
see nice um
kind of like mouth grills over here nice
blue metallic sheen
of course you might be wondering are
these wearable they are not uh they're
kind of fixed into place so you can't
pull it out
yeah
it's very very cool
let's take a look at the top of the head
here and you can see it's nice
kind of like
hand sewn
leather mask over here it's very cool
very big in terms of weight
it's pretty light
there's no issues carrying it
but uh
so it's hard to tell whether this is
metal or plastic but uh
before it seems seems like plastic let
me
or it could be hard plastic assuming
that you know
this kind of metal can be magnetized but
it could be
some aluminum something else who knows
so comparing the two bust
you can see that in terms of height
and width it's pretty much the same
in terms of scale it's pretty much the
same
yeah it's just it's just so iconic
you've got something that's more
shrouded more hooded you scorpion over
here and then subzero is more
ninja style
very very uh very different very iconic
from the from the both of them
even the the eye
the eye holes i'm just going to say eye
holes
or the eye cutouts very different from
zero scorpion obviously
but uh
yeah i read the level of details on both
of these things i mean the level of
detail on both of these are just simply
awesome
and of course if you are a model combat
fan
i think you guys will love this
so of course comparing this to
you can see that there are significant
color improvements in in terms of the
sub zero the the leather here it's much
on the darker shade of black with a
little kind of semi gloss kind of like a
satin gloss finish
over here well this is the older version
when it came out so you can see that
hood is more matte
more dusty
if the scorpio could have followed this
style would be so much nicer wouldn't it
be
but yeah that's about it so of course
going back to the game here we have the
mortal kombat
ps5 disc
looks super awesome
yeah
nice big bs5 words over there we can't
wait to play it
what we also have is the mono combat
ultimate warrior skin pack
here that we were not gonna give this
away because we're gonna play it
as well as the combat pack one and two
uh dlc
that we have here so yeah
so that's the end of the video my fellow
geeks if you enjoyed this please do give
us a thumbs up and don't forget to smash
that notification bell icon so you can
stay updated to our latest unboxings
geeky reviews and tidbits
see you guys on the next video and until
then this is zaki signing off
you